[Musique]
les
frontière terrestre aérien et maritime
du cameroun seront fermés tous les vols
passagers en provenance de l'étranger
seront suspendus à l'exception de voir à
bout et de la vire transportant les
produits de consommation augmentent
ainsi que les biens des matériels
essentiels dans le temps d'escale seront
limitées et encadré
on doit
le commerçant qui faisont qui nous qui
faisions nos ravitaillements du côté de
la chine
oui on ne parvient plus à voyager à afin
de se ravitailler
ouais ce qui fait que
nous sommes pratiquement en rupture de
stock bon ça fait depuis pratiquement
trois mois que nous sommes stables
alors qu'on a l'habitude de voir au
moins une à deux fois par mois dans ça
vraiment paralyser nos secteurs
d'activité que vraiment ça ça nous
empêche franchement d'avancé dit même du
côté de l'italie parce que leur habitat
aussi là bas en europe
[Musique]